in the last video we saw how a blood
sugar concentration or glucose
concentration in your blood of 80
milligrams per deciliter 80 milligrams
per deciliter was kind of a normal
fasting blood glucose if you hadn't
eaten for eight hours or before a meal
and the fancy word we learned in the
last video was pre prandial what I want
to do in this video because eighty
milligrams per deciliter really doesn't
make a lot of tangible sense to me I
don't know exactly how much sugar that
is what I want to do is try to put this
into different units so that we can
better conceptualize how much sugar that
might be in our body so let's just do a
little bit of unit analysis over here so
if we have eighty eighty milligrams per
deciliter that's what we're talking
about that's a normal fasting blood
glucose level now let's think about how
much that is per liter a deciliter is a
tenth of a liter so if we want to cancel
out the units we want deciliters we have
deciliters in the denominator here so we
want another deciliter in the numerator
so we want to know deciliters per liter
because then that and that will cancel
out and there are ten deciliters per
liter there are ten deciliters per liter
and so that gives us 80 times 10 is 800
milligrams 800 milligrams per deciliter
is cancel out milligrams per liter now
if we want that in terms of grams we can
just multiply we want to get rid of this
milligram so we want that in the
denominator milligrams we want grams per
milligram one gram is 1000 milligrams so
once again milligrams cancel out and
then you have 800 divided by a thousand
so 800 over a thousand is 0.8 grams per
liter grams per liter and let me start
over here so we have 0.8 grams per liter
and then to make sense relative to a
normal human body I look this up on the
internet the average human body missile
you I'm assuming I'm like five nine 150
pounds I think I'm pretty close to
average but they say the average human
body has about
five litres of blood so let's multiply
this times five liters per human per
average human obviously a small human
will have less and and a very large
person will have more blood flowing
through them but this is an average
person right over here so then we get
the liters cancel out
and so we get 0.8 times five eight times
five is forty point eight times five and
have one decimal place it's going to be
four eight point eight times five is
four and then we have grams per human
four grams per human and just to get an
idea of what four grams all are one
teaspoon 1 teaspoon 1 teaspoon is equal
to four point two grams so four grams is
almost a teaspoon so it's approximately
it's approximately one teaspoon 1
teaspoon of glucose per human being so
in your entire bloodstream you have
about a teaspoon of sugar that your
cells can use to do whatever cells need
to do